les biens je vais juste choquée que tout
soit bien parti
j'espère que tout va bien partir dans
les régions entre un check et de mon
côté j'ai l'impression qu'on est bon de
chez pons dans l'air j'ai juste eu un
petit coup de doute à au monde lance et
ne pas m'être trompé de m'acharner
salaires d'être bon écoutez ça a l'air
d'être bon ça a même l'air d'être très
bon salue l'homme sheth salut à toi et
bah oui c'est bon on est bien non mais
j'ai eu un coup de fusil ou est-ce que
je suis pas trompé ce qu'on espère sur
la chaîne big screen là est ce que est
ce que ça se passe bien mais bon ne
t'inquiète pas ça bien se passer bien se
passer merci loch ness
comment ça se passe pour vous
salut à gavin attend le grand salut à
paquito fillon brahms
les mecs aujourd'hui je stream
demain je ne serai pas demain tonton
qu'elle se repose et et jeudi à midi
tonton qu'elle se repose aussi j'ai je
sentais que j'étais fatigué j'ai regardé
mon visage dans le miroir ce matin et je
me suis dit ouais et là je le vois la
cam tonton kiev et chez il a besoin
d'eux il a besoin d'un temps mort comme
aurait dit vous bas je demande un temps
mort parce qu'on se fait qu'à nos scores
g stream est sans cesse mais j'ai besoin
fait ça va mais clairement il va falloir
que demain
time out ce qui est une chorale
ouais il faut qu'il faut que je la m
mais demain demain time out
quand même court arena avec sami robin
et à et après demain au 6 mai mais donc
ouais je vous préviens mes trois plus de
aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui elle
title tu faisais encore que j'ai très
envie de jouer et après demain ouais je
vais plus me ça y est après demain aussi
alors on peut pas créer de tournoi c'est
ballot sa bomba sinon on va se greffer
sur une autre arène trop de stream tu le
stream
oh non je crois pas non c'est bien quand
même de screen est souvent faim je suis
pas
moi j'aime bien en fait c'est juste qu'à
un moment donné faut que je puis on
s'est un peu quoi c'est plus ça mais on
soit je suis très heureux quoi sinon en
soit je suis très heureux mais mais
juste
je suis mais bientôt 24 heures mais
c'est beaucoup 24 heures
pacy talons à dormir en stream sur
twitter par contre fait gaffe et paquito
pense que si tu dors en stream
ils peuvent théoriquement tu te ban
on va se greffer sur une arène du coup
pour qu'on se grefferait pas sur une
arène en 960 ça change un peu
ou en système suisse en cinq rondes
c'est un peu léger
je suis en train de regarder un peu 10 +
0 c'est un peu beaucoup
il ya toujours celle de way système
suisse le problème c'est qu'on a plein
qui pourront pas s'inscrire
après y'a 3 0 en 960 vous n'êtes l'on
peut tenter celle là qui sera un peu
plus courte
on ne peut pas créer de tournoi
aujourd'hui elle cherche comme ils ont
des nouveaux ouais on peut on peut
tenter celle là celle que mes zimmer
zinédine zidane elle commence dans dix
minutes c'est notre heure normale et du
cou et du coup ça en trois sens 960 ça
change un peu ma foi pourquoi pas et
venez on vient on va dans celle là ça
change un peu les 960 ça fait une
variation par rapport à ce qu'on fait
d'habitude et salue florian c'est quoi
une abstention de ces les échecs 960 ça
change ça change ça change ça fait
découvrir un nouveau truc et puis on
profite au moins on profite du du
problème pour pour découvrir et système
suisse c'est un système de tournoi
normal pas comme les arènes où les gens
au système suisse c'est comme c'est
comme et a été accusé par exemple le
rock il faut aller vers sa tour vous
allez voir je vous montrerai
concrètement quand il y aura des partis
mais il faut juste aller vers sa tour et
ça va faire un roc normale et tu prends
ton roi tu le posera verte à tour et si
ya pas de pièces entre eux et ben ça
fera un roc normal en fait pour le grand
est pour le petit sais pas si tu connais
julien martin y tape règles mondiales au
poker et je connais pas et qui regardent
régulièrement mon live mais en fait ça
pourrait être cool d'essayer d'organiser
un petit tournant avec les joueurs de
poker peut-être et les streamer tu
jamais florian sainte tu le connais un
peu et qui peut me contacter pascale
guillon diaz que je connais qui joue un
petit peu mais peut-être y aurait moyen
de faire un petit tournant avec eux
aussi ce pourrait être sympa pourquoi
pas
un jeune papa un toit avec une ouverture
thématique à l'occasion et je sais pas
si ça s'organise sur tu fais comme est
ce que tu as vu il ya richard wach de la
grotte bah oui je sais on était dans le
chatt al trolls et donc j'ai bien vu on
est et on était peut-être je sais pas
combien on était à trouver les icare
brouillard dont le dans le chat et sur
quels sites de poker il joue guillaume
diaz et je sais pas et je pense qu'il
doit être je crois qu'il est sponso par
winamax mais je vais pas dire de bêtises
je ne préfère pas trop m'avancer mais je
pense qu'ils jouent sur wii naret
ils savaient pas qu'ils avaient vrai il
ya les doigts il doit bien être des
joueurs de poker qui regardent la chaîne
de toute façon toutes façons j'imagine
que les gens qui sont passionnés et des
chèques et qui regardent des chaînes
youtube donc les jeunes en gros il
regarde il regarde la chaîne bitstream
très clairement non
tu peux tu pourras tu peux écrire sur
twitter son nom s'te plaît florian sur
mon twitter mpv ritalin tes doigts et
car oui les divers italien tête quoi fin
hikaru en sueur hikaru hikaru en sueur
face à l'élite quoi il se rappelle
encore de la partie où il avait perdu en
quatre coups un voilà un jeu avait
mangée la dame dont que bon faut le
savoir il a décidé cette année c'est
joli carré sur son life style & karoui
l'étape mais qui a été voir la gym de
potez après je crois beaucoup à g n je
crois beaucoup
enfin pas qui c'était hier soir hikaru s
p hier soir c'était quand on arrête de
la chaîne d'hikaru et après martin et
engrossé 4 millions de gains en tournois
live
ouais c'est pas mal ça lui quand on trie
man city chine qichen 66 peser quelques
astuces de départ à prendre le centre et
jouer une partie jouée vite et bien
prendre le centre gagné une partie
pensé comme un grand maître développer
une pièce jouée un coup bas âge un vrai
beaucoup de conseils quand même qui me
paraissent à primordiaux n'a bougé une
pièce réfléchir gagné une partie est
jouée un coût sont quand même mis les
deux hyper importants comme conseils aux
nîmois où j'avoue j'ai été voir mais
franchement qu'est m
quand tu as pu retenir 15 secondes
devant la chine de voter j'ai pas tenu
plus de 5
j'avais trop honte pour elle ouais moi
aussi j'ai pas quand je dis qu'un second
c'était peut-être 3
franchement je me suis dit ça allait
trop loin le délire est allé trop loin
après c'est peut-être moi qui me dit ça
mais je me suis dit ils ont ils ont
poussé le délire trop loin
wake a roulé redif twitch c'est que pour
les abdos fred camaro moi aussi petit à
petit je voulais faire ça mais le truc
c'est chalco vide 19 qui arrivait et je
me suis dit qu'en cette période de
confinement se serait salle de commencer
sa de commencer à les redifs france a
banni en vrai c'est surtout fait pour
que les gens qui ont twitté prime me
lâche l'amazone travail chez toi parce
que sinon ils doivent sur une autre
chaîne genre imaginons est un gars qui
suit hikaru et qui suit blitz stream
genre juste une bêtise 1 mais admettons
quelqu'un suit les deux chaînes et a du
coup ben il va forcément lâcher son
amazon prime chez car ou est pas sûr
bitstream
et du coup plus à des gens qui mettent
les rediffs on s'abonne ni plus ils
forcent les autres à faire ce que sinon
tous les prime vont chez les autres et
du coup moi je voulant mettre de plus en
plus dans les émissions fable et merci à
flot fille à faire pour le sahb merci
tonton mais à genre ouais les émissions
fab les émissions matt tous ces trucs là
en fait j'aurais j'aurais voulu le faire
j'aurais voulu les mettre dans sa bonne
ni où les parties pédagogique et tout ça
mais avec les grands maîtres un passage
où je suis seul mais du coup on fait
avec le co vide j'ai complètement
repousser cette histoire là parce que
bon voilà ça ne serait pas juste
mais voilà pourquoi je n'ai pas fait
mais en vrai ça va forcément y arriver
c'est obligatoire en fait c'est juste
que t'as faim tu as pas de choix à un
moment donné tu étais obligé en fait ces
six personnes le fait en fait personne à
le faire cesser un peu vous connaissez
le dilemme du prisonnier ou en fait si
personne parle personne ne va en prison
et si on a un qui parle il va pas en
prison et tous les autres y vont et en
fait individuellement tout le monde a
intérêt à parler mais collectivement
personne n'a intérêt
c'est le dilemme du prisonnier
bâle a en gros avec les twitch prime
c'est la même chose c'est juste que six
personnes mêlant saboni les rediff bas
ça va mais le problème c'est quand tout
le monde le fais pas tu es obligé de
faire aussi celle du prisonnier
mais je pense que c'est un dilemme très
profond dans l'humanité en fait
genre si tout le monde se comporte bien
tout le monde vit mieux mais il suffit
qu'il y en ait un qui met la s et c'est
l'art est pour tout le monde
ouais c'est un seul parti là même une
récompense mais vraiment chez moi ça
grésille attendait est-ce que ça
grésille avoue me fait flipper toujours
mais dont quoi et du coup c'est un peu
ce même système moi c'est pour revenir
c'était ce même ces semaines dilemme
avec c'est ce même dilemme avec les avec
les rediff à votre ado d'un mari mais en
fait c'est pas c'est pas sur ceux qui le
font en dernier qu'il faut gueuler c'est
sûr ceux qui le font premier en fait
c'est toujours pareil
c'est toujours pareil c'est pas sur ceux
qui sont obligés de suivre le train
après tu vas faire quoi tu été bloquée
c'est sûr ceux qui commencent le truc
alors après c'est toujours des modes qui
viennent des états unis puis qu'ils
viennent chez nous c'est souvent ça
s'est souvent les américains qui font en
premier puis après du coup il ya tout le
monde qui suit derrière
donc ce soit pour les choses bien ou pas
bien d'ailleurs mais ça vient les modes
sur sur le sur le sur le stream game ça
vient souvent des us et ça ça revient
chez nous petit à petit quoi à 1960 ça
va être cool hein franchement ça va être
sympa ça va changer on va avoir des rocs
on va voir des trucs
il est cool et littéraire du chaos
pendant la douelle et non mais il est
très cool hikaru
après pour les lots faut faire gaffe
parce que c'est des lots 960 ça veut
absolument rien dire vous pouvez avoir
des gars qui sont tous en 960 et qui
sont 2003 faut faire gaffe on va suivre
la tête de série numéro 1 déjà pour
commencer
donc voyez le 960 le délire c'est que la
position est complètement random et là
en fait il a enfin ils ont les deux un
peu de chance ils ont les fous qui sont
bien placés dans les diago donc si les
blancs enlève le cavalier la dame et ce
cavalier là ils pourront faire un petit
rock et le roi se retrouvera ici et s'il
fait le grand roque du coup bah c'est la
tour qui bougera là pour faire comme un
grand rôle classique donc là il pourrait
faire grand cas
après c'est pas trop dans son intérêt
parce qu'il a peut-être envie de se
garder l'option de mettre le roi ici ou
ou garder ici je vis ici qui dit je
conseille à mes amis les rediff mes amis
viennent ensuite sur les lives et ça
fait ces mêmes amis finissent ensuite
possession par s'abonner n'est-il pas
plus bénéfique cette mentalité plutôt
que de priver les non connaisseurs de
twitch avec un oui et non j 6 qui en
fait un oui et non ce serait mieux si
c'est ce que j'explique est à l'ars et
c'est le dilemme du prisonnier c'est à
dire que si tout le monde à cet esprit
là c'est mieux pour tout le monde ne pas
mettre les rediff payante genre tout le
monde a intérêt à ce qu'elle les rediff
soit gratuite après si tu as tout le
monde qui met les rediff payante est de
plus en plus de streamer échec qui le
font donc les rediff pour les abo du
coup comme j'expliquais tatata j'sais
pas moi ça j'ai pas croire ça pourrait
me faire perdre de twitch prime et
imaginons ça m'a fait perdre 400 kg une
bêtise j'en ai pas 400 des tweets prime
imaginons la chaîne grandi machin on va
prendre 400 on va imaginer que l'on soit
dans un game qui sont un peu plus gros
vingt quatre centres heinz a fait ça
fait 700 dollars par mois et 700 dollars
par mois ça me permet de financer des
émissions avec fable les émissions avec
mathieu cornette et moi de pastry mais
pour absolument 0 tu vois c'est ça le
problème c'est quand même si personne le
fait personne le fait mais et si tout le
monde le fait et que du coup tous les
prêts ni par autre part d'autre part ben
tu vois le truc
donc tu as raison d'un côté gisci fatah
complètement raison en fait de base mais
du coup tu es un peu
tu étais un peu tu es un peu tu es un
peu bloquée après comme je dis là pour
le monde façon c'est pas d'actualité
tant que le la crise du coc vide machin
n'est pas fini de façon ce sera pas le
cas donc ça peut durer encore le te dire
on a le temps et après dans un an ou six
mois ou un an quand ce sera fini on
verra ouais mais tu peux aussi coupé la
poire en deux alfredo l'agent clamé ce
que j'expliquais à moi c'est ce que je
voulais faire mettre juste les rediff
des émissions avec les grands maîtres
donc ça fait 25 % des stream 20% des
stream et tout le reste le laissant
gratuit moi c'est l'idée mais bon là je
me répète un petit peu un mais mais mais
vu l'a vu les circonstances on va
attendre qu'à une position intéressante
ici et merci à j ce qui du coup pour
l'abonnement de niveau 1
donc ériger trois c'était le seul
intérêt du gratuite aura plus de
charisme
c'est pas faux mais trucks que charisme
ça fait pas à manger sinon je serais je
mangerai beaucoup plus bien sûr
faut-il le savoir est donc il ya eu le
plan f5 maugrée un mot grec qui m'a
l'air d'avoir une super pose là ils sont
tous les deux partis avec du gros rock
c'était marrant c'est bon tu l'as tu les
rediff aux seuls gisci ramasser les
rediff jazz comme une balle et redit
bitstream à elle est où la voix de
chasse comme ne tardera pas à voir les
relie blitz crime geste comme il voulait
dans choses comme je les ai convaincus
ne pas le faire pour le français fouet
deux tours j'ai 3
annoncée du tabac cet essai dès ce
mois-ci là depuis un mois sur les stream
entre les stream en soi pour tu as comme
pour bitstream les préparations les
trucs à écrire et où j'ai bien dû faire
ça a bien dû me prendre entre 40 et
soirée les youtube et machin l'as tu
prends toutes les vidéos mis bout-à-bout
ça a dû me prendre entre 45 et 60 heures
par semaine là depuis en moins donc
ouais c'est du taf c'est carrément du
taf
ouais c'était pas passionner tu peux pas
le faire de façon c'est pas possible
et là il va taper la tour en 1 8 et
peut-être six fours g4 encore pour lui
en revue remettre une petite ya juste le
fois un cas un peu triste soirée qu'il
n'y a pas fait grand chose de la game
bon alors il a quoi il a deux cas loge
de +2 calloc'h de plus mais il a un ou
deux qui joue pas mais il va falloir
peut-être d'un match de damages set
n'aurait pour aller gratter pions h
il peut être utile ça enlèvera toujours
un pion passer un jour s'il arrive en h4
peu pénible en plus la dame est là elle
rentre et maintenant il va falloir
mettre des petits coups de savates au
roi et réfléchir comment le coin c'est
bon ça à gagner pour maugrée donc je
remets le lien dans le chatt laquelle je
conseille à quelqu'un à prendre les joue
aux échecs bas si vous pouvez si vous
avez un enfant à partir de 5-6 ans est
possible de lui apprendre suivant à quel
point il est réceptif mais il faut qu'il
y ait quand même une envie info jamais
forcer un les échecs façon c'est une
passion un soi soit on aime soit on aime
fin où là il y avait une tour en
oulalalala il est il a échappé belle
maugrey là son adversaire lui fait fou
prend f1 et la partie tourne un après il
ya peu de temps mais ça aurait pu
ça aurait pu tourner en tout cas ça a
tourné côté maugrey ouh là là on joue on
regarde des joueurs
un iranien contre un bulgare ça n'a
aucun rapport avec nous
your are triche est dans ta face au
tchad entame assez intéressant
parce que je trouve qu aux échecs
normaux il a un peu faiblard en ratings
a fait j 4 as well as tours et angers 1
et le fond h un très très très bien joué
à rien et qui a paru si haïti fait ça
arrive les bugs de motifs ça arrive
l'époque de motifs donc question c'est
vraiment de quel côté il va moi j'aime
bien les noirs là j'aime bien les noirs
parce que le roi blanc il a plus trop
d'endroits où se cacher les noirs ils
ont réussi à se créer une maison
le four en h1 il est dégueu gouaille on
a move est fou contre bons fous le roi
n'a plus de gaz les cavaliers n'ont
aucune activité lui les oreilles aurait
coupé aura et coupe ettu plus personne
n'a d'oreille dans cette position et
c'est un vrai problème c'est un vrai
problème pour les blancs ici al cavalli
qui arrive en 3 le fou qui va venir
angers 4 peut-être aller difficile cette
position pour les blancs le roi est
vraiment mauvais les pièces sont mal
placés maintenant un petit d'amd 8 qui
touche le 1960 tu peux parfois vraiment
avoir une position écrasante contre un
mec plus faibles écrasé un mec plus fort
c'est c'est beaucoup plus aléatoire
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait chez shinhan de
yoga olalala gaffe mais en 960 il ya
beaucoup plus de gars comme ça les
pièces sont placés de manière
inhabituelle et ça fait et ça fait
craquer tiens on va regarder barbarian
qu'est ce qui donne les jeux contre j
qu'il aime en fait voir de quoi c'est
parti c'est aussi partie d'un g4 donc
l'appareil tu as le roi en b1 au début
donc si tu fais grand europe le roi il
va passer en c1 et la tour en d1 et si
tu vas faire petit rock tu peux
carrément partir de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier
donc en réalité
bon là ça a pu être le cas parce que les
tours vont s' mais là tu as peut-être
intérêt à faire grand roque quand même
un moment donné pour réussir à faire
jouer la tour c'est fait mais j'aime
bien les blancs ont regardé le fou j'ai
2 comment y brille par rapport aux fous
caillé qui peut venir en d5 avec 4,6
peut-être c'est vraiment un jeu
intéressant
la tension à colonna s'était passé
habituel ouais mais le truc c'est que
comme tout est inhabituelle autour en
fait à tête elle se mélange à peut-être
un petit coup de fous des cinq épreuves
et roi fou prend break et prend à 5
aussi pourquoi pas parce que ok tout
reprend donc le roi est bien mais la
question est ce que la tour pourra
revenir en jeu après le contrôle une
case importante la case des 5
honnêtement c'est chaud c'est chaud de
night c'est chaud de knight
détour inquiets tourer est ce que ça
marche vraiment est peut-être mais bon
faut en b3 il est pas mal parce qu'ils
tapent dans cette diago où on sent qu'il
peut se passer des choses on peut
ramener d'arâches 4g 5 est le fruit tape
sur la diagonale maintenant il fait des
oui mesdames e3 et tuent au nom au non
non non mais pourquoi autant de gav dame
e3 tu frappe là où le bât blesse
la tour en a 5 elle joue plus
en gros la les blancs ils devaient
absolument jouer colonnes et surtout
qu'ils gagnaient le cavalier injuste
mais ils doivent absolument tirer profit
le plus vite possible de cette tour qui
est en jeu et surtout pas laisser b4
arriver c'est dommage
alors oui mais en tournoi de ces fous
par marianne vraiment il retourne
énormément de partie avec des poubelles
des pièces de moins les tours de moins
c'est fou je sais pas comment il fait
les magiciens il est magicien barbarian
il est magicien barbarian alors il
aurait une pièce de moins il était raide
de chaire est d'ailleurs bravo ans bravo
bien joué j'ai toujours étonné
évidemment de ces retournements de
barbarian mais c'est le beau jeu aussi
un c'est le beau joe g et maugréa
maugrée la sq il a lâché une nulle ouais
mais pas étonnant c'est quand je vous
disais c'est ça ça nivelle vraiment les
niveaux
revenez en garde le début de cette
partie des 16 à 9
donc il a joué le centre ouais ça c'est
logique c'est un genre de wiz et laissez
moi ce que j'aime bien quand on est un
peu comme ça c'est peut-être de bouffer
une fois et faire 4 pour essayer de
créer un d'attaquer le centre par la
suite avoir ainsi ses bons cavaliers à
six fours g5 mais ça fait pas un clouage
pas un pion prend est fou g5 bon à voir
c'est position compliquée mais a comme
vu comment s'est passée dans la partie
j'ai l'impression que les noirs là ils
sont très heureux parce qu'ils ont pris
énormément d'espacé au centre alors oui
ils ont le fou 17 qui est mauvais mais
toute façon il va venir jouer sur cette
diago qui peut se faire venir même
s'installer jusqu en d3 s'ils le
souhaitent
et ils ont tout l'espace au centre les
noirs avec un votre mac cic 1963 écoute
comme y avait un problème de création
tour assure chasse comme on a décidé de
de tenter quelque chose et la foulée 5
en plus la tour f 1 et enfermer les
mêmes je voulais juste parler
stratégiquement du placement de pièces
et c'est super bien joué de la part du
baron fou mais comme toujours les
parties peuvent se retourner en 960
parce que les positions sont étrangers
du coup il ya plus de gaffes
alors là c'est ça s'empire en revanche
pour les blancs puisque maintenant il ya
deux pièces attaqué et il n'y a pas de
rebond salvateur et donc ça va faire
enfler le score est bas rend fou qui
l'emportent
alors on va retourner à avoir cet ancien
questa chèque qui aujourd'hui leader
pour le moment du tournoi
alors on va suivre la partie on va
revenir du début donc là encore ils ont
voulu faire jouer les fous et à l'écart
et j'ai cinq cavaliers f3 été un peu
naïf je n'aime pas trop les noirs il
s'est laissé rentrer dedans et les
blancs il s'apprend de l'espace et
prendre le centre est maintenant ah
ouais ils réussissent à avoir une
position
j'allais dire une bonne position sauf
que il ya une double attaque et c'est
les noirs qui vont réussir à gratter ici
il faut encore faire gaffe accueilli ces
quatre des six avec des rebonds il a
fait dame prend b6 et dames b1 et
maintenant où il ya kariya 5 qui tombe
et staff iec pas qui est complètement
gagnant du pouf alors là attention au
matin en 1
et aux prochains mois ce qui ferait que
les noirs c'est que je sacrifierais fou
histoire de passion il ya une tour en
food avance histoire de régler ça mais
ils sacrifient la tour j'aurais plutôt
sacrifier le fou parce que une tour ans
et 8 serait plus utile
là il est capable de faire dame détroit
et par la dame 1 je vous dis tout de
suite mais il aurait été plus utile
d'avoir une tour derrière pour faire du
dam des quatre tours ces deux cas voir
le flash 8on qui sort après 1 mais qui
est pas qu'ils aient pas ou feint une
tour était mieux quoi va forcément se
sont entourés plus forte un de base et
gilles cossic demande le lien et voilà
le lien
attention aujourd'hui c'est en 960 m ji
cosmi ffu c3
donc ils attaquent la tour et il craint
pas d'apprendre et s'ils s'y prendre à
justin façon et pas grand chose on va
voir s'ils concluent qu'une 38 secondes
attention ne pas faire tout réfuté adam
prend dames c'est quand même un beau
piège
peut-être les blancs au mas de la tour
en e2 pour être tous protégés de partout
possible
tours f1 d'accord je pense va émettre
laurent h3 méroise froide un f5 dans les
trois mois la télé change les dames tu
recules le fou un f6 et envoie le pion
bessat fini au nom au nom c'est à chier
ah oui mais il a plus de temps à assez
incroyable il était il était leader du
tournoi et il a perdu sur le tour prend
ces trois mon avis hein quand on a vu la
sacrifier la tour lieu de sacrifier
juste un fou et avoir une victoire
facile derrière
malheureusement il perd la tour oh la la
c'est là c'est la foire d'empoigné là
c'est la foire d'empoigné ipray lyprendi
prend pas les pions et tout quoi s'est
il va envoyer son pion à lui et cet
échec qui va perdre
cruel pour lui mais après ouais ce
sacrifice mauvais réflexe il pourra
abandonner un ça va pas aller bien loin
alors on peut aller voir un peu de
ragonneau
alors faites moi voir cette partie
alors ouais mon pays c'est six f4 tour
17 et là il a fait qu'elle g6 il a joué
un grand rôle qui était pas mal joué
pour faire rentrer la torah j'aime bien
ce qu'a fait dragon ball avec le grand
roque le pour prendre de la dame est et
le fou est enfermé et sur fc 4 adam parr
f3 et sur dame prend ton france et
quatre tours prendrait trois en plus il
attaquera partout donc il va gagner mais
le petit tour des sept grands rock était
vraiment bien pensé un bien joué à drago
nos allées voir barbarian et on retombe
barbarian comme il vient de commencer
il joue contre un joueur us arize on
fait quoi position était marrante au
début 4 5e de calais 3g 3g si des 3 5
lycées 3par donc c'est à symétrie est
perdu
donc le roi pourrait aller à faire un
grand roque a tous un petit rock à tout
moment
c'est sa toute la finesse du jeu en fait
avec le roi c'est pas facile tu peux tu
peux penser une stratégie pour plus tard
avoir ton roi à l'abri
j'aime pas pour les blancs le fait que
les noirs et réussi à envoyer un pion f4
comme ça et puis commencer par celle ci
peut-être pu reprendre
ma position est compliqué c'est qu'il va
réussir à faire ces trois décades j'aime
bien les blancs mais après les fouilles
sont bloqués avec l'avantagé noir c'est
noir des beaux fous attention aussi à la
tour e 1 qui peut être dans un vis-à-vis
désagréable je pense que grand roque
c'est bien joué ça permet de régler le
problème de la première rangée
combien de temps il faut pour être bon
aux échecs tous les ans que tu appelles
bon hein
c'est tellement difficile comme notion
de bon mauvais bien jouer mal joué si on
est toujours le bond de 4 cas ils
mauvais de quelqu'un d'autre un on va
dire que pour commencer à comprendre un
peu ce qui se passe quelques mois mais
bon c'est vraiment subjectif kg 5 parce
que le truc si tu gagnes h3 quand même
après un jour tu as les calamars et un
quai à tue-tête échanges essayer de
jouer à j'assume et le pion à f3
je me demandais ce que f 3 ar 3 tu
restes et c'était vraiment une question
pour moi parce que si tu réussis à à
faire survivre le gars joue à dire que
le fou h 1
il va plus exister de la partie mais
genre vraiment plus sert en fait il
pourra pique même pas il pourra pas
bouger de la partie donc elle croise
était hyper thématiques
après le prime de soi chat sacrifices
qu'il a plus le temps
il a juste plus de temps ouais ça va
faire une nouvelle victoire de barbarian
fois juge et 3h 4ème et le temps que tu
fasses tout ça si le pion sur vita comme
une pièce de plus sur l'autre aile un
bon les noirs sont écrasants et afu
prend mais bon il reste cinq secondes ça
va gagner pour barbarian très
tranquillement intéressant donc pour le
moment et 202 joueurs donc à kemp arendt
de manéah expo exposé 63 ouhlala c'est
une position un peu compliqué parce que
les fous sont très mal placés au début
la dame aussi les cavaliers aussi là
c'est une position où rien n'est bien
alors ça ça trouve la case f6 se trouve
la case à vii c'est bien joué et lui il
va essayer de le mettre en c6 j'imagine
rapidement avant que le train arrivant
en f3 ce qui est plutôt bien pour lui
puisqu'il retrouverait plus jouer fouet
f3 direct mais le fait qu'ils
réussissent à arriver en c6 c'est assez
intéressant pour lui pourquoi il ya
autant de monde non parce qu'on a parce
que c'est pas une arena à nous en fait
on s'est greffée sur une autre aréna et
on a beaucoup de nos mecs qui sont venus
nantenaina donc ça ça mais c'est énorme
pour une aréna de 960 habituellement n'y
a pas autant de monde pour le 960
habituellement il ya beaucoup moins de
monde juste là du coup on est et lustres
greffer dessus et on est nombreux salut
poupine à tort et épreuve 4 est toujours
un attention autour non liée là faut
faire gaffe à la double attaque à yanbu
qui tombe il n'a pas vu
fallait évidemment prendre en c3 d'abord
si reprenant ces trois maintenant
pendant des 5 et 6 prenant des ans et 6
vous pouvez ramener le front alf s'y
soumettent peut-être même en d4 de
manière plus ambitieuse et à vous l'avez
peut-être qu'en europe qui était chiant
mais en gros c'est dommage d'avoir
laissé cette pièce
alors maintenant j'imagine qu'il va
vouloir tenter de ouais mais le truc
c'est que en plus qui va pas du tout
c'est qu'il a tous les pions sur blanc
et il s'est fixé sur cases noires il est
complètement bloqué
mais les gars sont vraiment plus
fréquentes en 960 j'ai déjà remarqué
quand je jouais à l'hfr b4 faut envoyer
la famille adam prend même là il est
fixé à les reprendre de a
maître laurent bessette la tour en 1 8 à
3 baisse est quand même restée bien
jouer la torah 8 s et bien il ya dès
qu'il ya de la conviction mais l'autre
blinde
il réussit pas à faire b4 c'est le
problème il est fixé sur noir et pour la
peine il est vraiment bien fixé 1
foot et 7 on va pouvoir faire
éventuellement c5 qui avait tombé cette
bien jouer n'arrive pas à organiser quoi
que ce soit qui en d4 2009 ou en plus
s'il avait tant de faire ces cinq de
chasser le cavalier mais il n'a pas le
temps maintenant la tour retrouve plus
d'endroits la tente dans ce qu'il peut
mais ça rende sa rente un cavalier va
pouvoir rejoindre l' attaquent une
dernière pièce il passe par bara g4
merrer ok ils essayent de créer un allez
peut-être d'amasha imeda ma chance et de
il se fait contrer en toi je cuisine il
aurait menacé c'est un échec cavaliers
pour un jour de perpète
ou la déconnexion avec dams est mat
c'était le problème à être pièce sur son
roi il pouvait pas contre attaque et au
pin ou perf arrive à bord ban qui va
encore gagner autant y est
impressionnant ce barbarian amélie gagné
en plus alors on va encore changer de
parti on va aller un peu plus bas dans
le classement à quel j'ai le droit tient
ou pas on le regarde souvent qu avait le
droit
grand maître gims monde qu'on l'a pas vu
grand maître gims laura parti depuis le
début ça s'est passé de manière
intéressante la dame ancien ghetto
quartier il va pouvoir mettre influencé
6 peut-être mais aussi sur des cavaliers
à cinq qui ont rôdé
elle a pas vus fou prend 17 c'est parce
qu'il a oublié la dame en achat au
caylar et perrine calloc'h c'est une
partie un peu décousu 1
je pense vraiment ok cavalia quatre
seraient plus forts évidemment
fourchette mais sinon dézinguer ça est
ramenée à y ramener la dame en jeu
peut-être tout rue à tours 8 tu as dit
que c'est vrai mais cette dame j'ai
cette dame e set mais a ramené ramener
les pièces en jeu et finir le boulot
c'est important la même tour prend aussi
ce marchand d'armes françaises et 3,8 et
il n'y a plus rien après je pense qu'il
avait raté trois à six aussi une option
d'ailleurs et toutes les cases couverte
dame c8 qui arrivent et sur damas trois
on revient en bessette les blancs
peuvent pas vraiment attaquer les cases
blanches de toute façon
ouais c'est une variante c'est une belle
variante 1 d'ailleurs c'est une très
belle variantes
c'est une variante vraiment sympa moi
j'aime bien même beaucoup ça change
vraiment des échecs c'est cool de
pouvoir le faire une fois de temps en
temps mon tour cas très bientôt en pls
ouais c'est ça change d'âme ses six à
les chasser cette dame là quand m
higgins histoire y arriver en tête ont
acquis on nous a dit on n'avait pas
quito on a pas mal de joueurs qui a se
partagent la tête
beaucoup de joueurs à 17 points en fait
à l'avancé 6
d'amd 5 avec faut continuer à le
chantage la halle échange m la tour en
e2 puis la dame henri iv est allée est
allé chercher à l'avancé là il peut
revenir on des huit avec l'arabie donc
c'est pas grave il se passe rien mais
allez une tour en deux une dame le katla
l'harmonie ça c'est dommage de pas voir
cette harmonie la tour 2 puis on protège
la dame protège sa et la dame rose 4
tous entre eux protègent et on tape là
ça c'est vraiment des choses importantes
à avoir cette harmonie de deux pièces
avec tous qui centre protège pour
avancer ça permet de ne pas prendre le
moindre risque la dame f5 important et
voir la suite harmonique est perdu
heureusement que le tableau abena
produits avaient faim d'armes encore ya
les tours france et deux tours à 2 et
l'a peut-être damev quatre c4 dam des
deux ment il prend la dame et là j'ai vu
cette dame ses cinq matches en un raté
et il va la perdre à l'équipe france et
qu'adam des six damage deux pays ces
quatre noms arrivent à la perdre il va
la perdre c'est sûr dommage pour grand
maître gims ça manque un peu de qualité
ans
en flag on à gaby j'aime bien ce qu'il a
fait avec les noirs il a fait le petit
mur contre ça et il s'est ouvert lui
mais après ce que c'est vraiment bon ça
c'est une autre question
alors ils ont fait les blancs en pâtit
malgré le fait qu'ils sont en retard ils
auraient pu faire au lieu d'avancer ses
pions et de se retrouver sous la foudre
de toutes les pièces en fait les pièces
de des deux côtés l artac là l attaque
plutôt allèles dames et les blancs ils
ont revu intérêt aussi à faire petit
rock
en fait c'est laisser un peu sous les
foudres de l'attak
d'un autre côté les noirs ils sont un
peu ratée en laissant leur refus en c3
fallait garder la colonne s'est ouverte
parce que ce fut en c3 ils bloquent
complètement l'attaquent noir les deux
joueurs ont assez mal attaqué dans cette
partie
je trouve
après c'est aussi une des difficultés
960 c'est qu'il faut être très complet
il faut bien jouer beaucoup de types de
dif deux positions différentes et c'est
pas évident enfin grand bailli pas assez
de temps pour le 960 moi aussi je
préfère qu'on sait en 5 + 0 après on
n'avait pas trop le choix
là on allait se greffer sur un truc pour
essayer oulaï adam prend des vêtements
il l'a pas vu elle a en plus c'est
vraiment pas de chance ce qui se fait
rebondir encore sur le fou bon ça va
encore gagner peut-être de manière plus
franche comme ça va prendre f5 ou là à
tours l2 tourcoing f5 c'est dommage de
ne pas être allé gratter le fond en a
quatre qui pouvait faire la découverte
et maintenant il ya x 3 échecs qui
arrive au prochain et où tour f1 matt
encore mieux aïe aïe aïe le joueur avec
les blancs la pièce offensive la plus
dangereuse c'est fou à 4 parce qu'il ya
des découvertes alors soit tu fais 3 1
mais tu donnes le trait à l'adversaire
soit tu fais ça et quand même tu prends
le x 4 mm si tu donnes le trait à
l'adversaire a supprimé sa plus forte
est d' attaque
c'est dommage de pas avoir vu cette
attaque longue
alors on va aller jeter un oeil à partie
d'awp l'art
je sais sur rue69 samson dans les arénas
king comme la saison dernière je crois
pas pour pina tort après j'espère qu'ils
ont décalé le début des arénas king pour
améliorer ce qu'ils avaient pensé faire
on verra bref c'est funky flex que macca
ils m'aiment bien je sais je sais
j'étais dans le chatt moi aussi je suis
saoul et mais très intéressant ça change
ainsi permis de voir autre chose a les
bleus ont perdu une pièce rapidement et
la partie va pas forcément être
passionnante maugrée tient maugréer ce
que fut difficile c'est plus difficile
de faire respecter la loi en 960 web
même si maugrée est bien classé cinq et
demi sur 6 mais c'est plusieurs de
gagner vite on peut moins un peu moins
profiter de nos connaissances allez on
va aller regarder ja ou non jacques jeu
verra j'ai raté jaout et ben du coup on
se trouve sa partie dig dig x 0 6 mois
déjà vu tout à l'heure
tiens manu guignard est ce que ça joue
vite aussi manu
4 g6 et gaby à 38 avec les blancs près
d'une position aux essais mais en fait
dans la dame et le cavalier inter à
intercaler c'est marrant cette position
normale sauf que là le cavaly la dame
sont sur des cases différentes
quasiment une position d'échec mais
c'est un détail qui peut changer
beaucoup
et manu qui veut mettre le cavalier 11,6
du coude ou il tapera sur f4 et des cats
a assez bien joué parce qu'ils jouent
une structure de type philidor ou pire
que tu vends à suivant et il va pouvoir
mais il veut mettre son cavalier e 6 et
du coup la dame elle est bien placée en
18 bon peut-être faire dams et damas et
sept autour des 8 mai et le cavaillon
réussissez s'abonnent casse dans cette
structure de pions donc manu qui a super
bien joué ici et qu'il a va pouvoir
aller soit sur f4 y avait aussi des
quatre où il y avait qu un voyage 5
aussi pour essayer d'en être sue la f4
et l'autre en précis au final d'avoir
cette ces deux cavaliers bien placé en
tout cas c'est assez intéressant comment
il a réussi à transposer dans une
position de son cavalier était mieux
aussi ce qu'en c6 et c'était vraiment
bien pensé de la part de manu
donc il va faire cavalier aussi serait
peut-être viser cette caste des cadres
dont on parlait et unique si je trouve
que c'est plus intéressant que les
quatre couleurs moi c'est la variante
des échecs qui m'intéresse le plus
personnellement parce que c'est celle
qui ressemble plus aux échecs
c'est à dire que en fait tes
connaissances aux échecs vont réellement
td a bien joué et plus tu seras un bon
joueur d'échecs mieux tu joueras en fait
il ya vraiment une
une relation de cause à effets très
directs avec les échecs cas là mieux
centrer c'est moi qui me suis mis bas
allez je l'avais sévères' c'est moi qui
me suis mis un peu pas
aïe le des rocks et bien là là en fait
c'est comme il fait vraiment une vraie
partie d'échecs face et une position
sauf que là il a attesté de parrot
qu'avec les mains mais il aurait pu le
faire mais c'est une position que tu
peux avoir dans une partie très normal
ça qui est intéressant et manu qui a
très bien joué parce qu'il a réussi à
tirer profit du cavalier en des 8 par
rapport à la dame en bibitte et ça
s'était très bien joué de la part de
manu à tour 8e 5 et dessins qui va jouer
les cases noires voilà il fait péter le
4 il fait tout péter
mais tous vraiment intéressant c'est
dommage de pas avoir un pion en un il ya
trop de petites scories dans le jeu
comme ça et ça lui françois ddd salut
ram spock
et salue bidouille bon après une feinte
schering et donc ce soir à 18 heures on
sera le titre eyetoy tuesday sur la
chaîne bitstream vous avez lien en
dessous si vous voulez le voir en 960 tu
peux même te retrouver mieux compte des
joueurs plus forts à la sortie de
l'ouverture la tête fois je suis peut
être intéressant ou à fislis peut-être
j'ai pas le truc c'est qu'il a laissé
les blancs quand même se consolider en
ne prenant pas le pion les cinq c'est ça
non
qui va jouer vite et faire tomber manu
va revenir h5 j'imagine lui faire h l'a
peut-être pas à 6 me fait revenir h16
après si vous voulez vraiment faire
tomber fait du salin dame sait si ce qui
est presque 4,5 pouces g7 gerber moment
ci voulait juste faire tomber
l'adversaire fait fait juste du trait
salins sarhane se fatiguer tu fais un
échec pour l'un pions tu fais un autre
échec prend à noter enfin tchéquie
étrangers 5 puis dame baissait depuis
tout reprendre 5 et tu fais du très sale
si vous êtes parti pour faire du sale
fait du salin et tu reprennes moudenc
bessette par contre tu dois prévoir deux
trois coups ralliera la file et tu dois
pu réfléchir
tu te prépares et kg cinq dames 17 tempo
fou prend aux cinq t'aurais pu déjà
faire trois pré move suite avait décidé
de faire du sale fête fête fête du sale
mais allez aller jusqu'au bout de votre
conviction quoi tient maugrée follet
contre crystal ça c'est intéressant
aussi en 960 voir inscrite à se faire on
va s'en sortir avec l'ouverture de qui
la joue un peu au sens d'accord suisse
qui a raté la reina et à jeudi soir
d'ailleurs à 20h30 on fera une arena
avec la ffe du coup une arena bitstream
alors pas vraiment il ya les faits
puisque ce sera une arena bitstream on
va dire qu'il ya les gens de la ffe qui
viendront participer et merci à dodo
miam miam pour le tweet prime merci
tonton
alors les blancs on devoir perdre quand
même un temps pour rockets parce que
sinon il ya toujours cette histoire de
tours et deux premières rangées fragile
et la tourache 1 qui participa après
peut-être faut aller prendre des six
intermédiaire c'est un problème cette
première rangée
c'est comme aux échecs normaux ne par ok
à un moment donné ça pose un ça pose un
vrai problème
un moment donné ça pose un vrai vrai
vrai problème il est obligé de perdre un
temps pour ok là tu peux pas garder une
tour si mal bon après rien n'est fait un
symbole phare y croise de tout re
d'affaires g3 c'est sûr j'irai quand
même plutôt fait rock l'hameçon que
c'est plus affaibli qu'autre chose
il vient d'où ce délire avec les tontons
je pense qu'il vient de bosses en fait à
michel à 28 m o des tontons du bled
aussi way vient tout un tas de petites
choses quoi écrite alors ça tu vas
devoir tenter d'intercepter le pion mais
ainsi qu'à foot et vidéo d'un lead avec
fat est partie pédagogique etc
merci dodo miam miam merci à toi adams
et quatre cavaliers trois canons ya pas
qu il ya eu trois puisqu'il est cloué à
ces dames c4 marche grâce au cloud âge à
il n'a pas vu le clouage et l'aréna je
vais te mettre le lien
alors maintenant il faut éviter car ie3
faut bouger le roi mais là ça marche
parce qu'il y aura dame prend d'amasser
quatre et maugréa et progrès qui va
gagner mais ce n'est pas content
d'arbaïn c'est contre mon gré et barbe à
rennes qui est leader du tournoi a bien
joué maugrey alors on va voir quand ils
s'en sortent contre visi ce joueur c'est
lettonie sawey une position de départ
encore un peu étranges cavaliers pas
très bien placé à dans les coins mais
faire enfin recomposé cie théâtrale fait
par petits rockeurs ça rendre au quai
pas idiot ce qui fait avec les blancs
une vraie logique mais maintenant le
problème c'est un peu cette case f5 quoi
c'est hyper compliqué je préfère les
noirs quand même mais la position est
loin d'être clair quatre prises aux
caprices des huit prises dvi est le
souci des noirs c'est qu'en fait le
cavalier à huit est toujours pas fin
l'avantagé noir c'est que la structure
des pions des blancs est un peu pourri
devant leur rock mais le problème c'est
que le cavalier à une sim pièce courte
portée et toujours pas développer les
cavaliers f k you 7 par contrat prendra
effet tu comprends pas où est le
problème
pourquoi avoir interdit qui avait lieu
cette
bien joué les tours d un sondage 35 adam
prend 1,5 et sur cavaliers f5 attendant
me prend 20 et dame prend f5
c'est bien joué très bien joué mais
carey le set c'était bizarre moi je le
cheikh depuis combien de temps moins
chaud aux échecs depuis à 26 ans je
pense les positions de départ vraiment
pourri en 1968 avec les fous au centre
les cavaliers n'importe où les dames
vrai t'as des positions plus harmonieuse
que d'autres on en avait une avec les
fois je suis à huit direct qui était sur
les grandes diagonales les cavaliers je
pense sur leur case de départ elles sont
bien les tours au centre et le roi
peut-être en ans et 8 ou quoi après tu
peux pas voir les tours tout de suite
bien étaient trois des huit tours 8 ou
quelque chose comme ça mais là les noirs
sont gagnant dès que le cavalier va
arriver en c4 on sentira la pièce de
plus lesquels j'ai le droit qui réussit
un gros tournant et les sixièmes la caf
j'ai le droit
il enchaîne una laquelle j'ai le droit
bordel à il a oublié la longue diagonale
qui a eu juste droit
la dame place en h1 qui traverse tout
l'échiquier pour à l'encaisser la tour
et aller 7 960 à ses 26 ans que je m'en
faire naturellement je viens en offrir
une petite je peux bien en offrir une
petite
naturel
oui
nantes
6 la tour en 1 là comme ça de cap j'ai
le droit
elle était un peu un peu moche hein
c'est dommage pour lui il était dans le
top 10 1 mais là il est en grande
difficulté l'encouragent quand même un
petit peu encore qu à l ouverture la
plaie pour les blancs la plus simple à
mémoriser dans tous ces variations mais
en fait le truc c'est que tu as autant
d'ouvertures que de position donc vu
qu'il en à 960 tu arriveras jamais rien
à apprendre juste faut jouer au centre
et ses d'activer ces pièces et trouver
de l'harmonie mais c'est difficile bien
évidemment à la même pas pris de
cavaliers cave j'ai le droit
960 moins celle que nous connaissons
assez serré il en reste 900 59
milan reste 959
alors j'ai envie de dire pourtant tu as
un siège sept cavaliers f3 mais tu vois
genre l'autre te fais damev cette île
menaces mat
tadam f1 mat du couloir ça pouvait être
un petit piège quand même bon c'est pas
fini encore ici un peu s'activer
problème c'est que ça va pas bien loin
d'amd 4 ab catella il ya m'attendre
dommage qu'elle faisait le droit qui
partait bien qu'ils avaient le droit
bordel mais qui a craqué alors on peut
jeter un oeil à sont dit tiens un petit
lots qui réussit bien aux adversaires à
700 d'avoir une bonne position laqué
noir avec un bouquin alliant cathéter
dame décide à me prends mes quatre les
pièces blanches sont pas super bien
placé
ça semble sympa c'est possible en 960 de
trouver sur celle de base oui
malheureusement tu as un peu deg mais ça
arrive
ces 5 on a quand même
il a une pièce de plus même j'avais pas
vu c'est vrai que le cas aujourd hui tu
vois pas trop mais du coup fef cinq
dames à 5 et 6 et 7 faut faire jouer le
cavaliere all hallow on dit heureusement
qui la fout prend 1,3 non mes cavaliers
français cette caisse qui me fais tu
fais un petit fou prendre trois tours l2
qui avait pensé cette c'est pas tout à
fait finie en mai -2 là j'ai pas rock
reprend f2 admettons pour montrer vitae
et un coup cavaliers ou six est en
réalité tu as du matos quand même pour
la dame mais là ce cavalier il n'a pas
du tout fait joué par contre ya le temps
c'est marrant il faut faire jouer toutes
ces pièces on le voit encore plus en 960
pour les amateurs c'est encore plus
flagrant que dans les échecs normaux
alors je me suis mal exprimé je reprends
la question avec un exemple système de
londres est facile à mémoriser à horizon
10 coups attend le système de londres
c'est une ouverture les plus compliquées
avec les blancs bon c'est pas plus
compliqué mais c'est hyper compliqué le
système de londres je sectionnant ne
joue pas la réponse optimale je suis en
théorie un avantage
ouais enfin c'est quand même un tout
dépend de ton niveau en fait on pourrait
dire ça sur plus ou moins toutes les
ouvertures au final système de monde
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus compliqué
que ce que les gens ne pensent alors
barbarian à barbarian qui est plus
peut-être maugrée qui peut qui peut
dépasser to you compte par tako vert à
mais une pièce de moins maugréer contre
par tako vert et pas très bien ce raid
écossaise la plus simple pour les blancs
non mais tout est compliqué françois en
fait il n'y a pas d'ouverture miracle ou
simple je suis environ 1800 m à 1800 le
système de londres si tu commences à
jouer contre des joueurs corrects c'est
hyper compliqué tu as plus intérêt à
jouer un candidat normal je pense la
foulée c'est un fou mais cinq étaient
peut-être plus intéressant tant que la
tour était attaqué le thème set j'ai
peut-être fait retour 1-1 a essayé de
rentrer en huit mois ils envoient les
pions il reste 4 14 pour lancer
barbarian qui est leader mais ça
pourrait revenir à et réussi à faire le
front des cinq maintenant qu'il a chassé
cavale car elle aussi c'est très bien
joué il attaque la dame qui reprend 17
il prendrait la dame en f4 peut-être
faire d'alger 3 maintenir la pression
elle est rentrée dans cette finale elle
n'est pas terrible donc maugrée fallen
qui va probablement disparaître
enfin ses chances de gainward par
probablement disparaître ça me paraît
difficile avec les plantes gagner ça
quand même
c'est une vraie tour de moins nette
il va faire pousser 6 l'autre maintenant
damphousse et 4 il veut s'en prendre à
lui de faire tout reprendre et 4 s'il a
envie surtout réduite à tour ses huit
tours 17 et mais n'importe quel coût
gagne mais bon toujours l'histoire du
temps je demande si fou j'ai 8 ans ferme
pas le fou à 4 jaffe food et 5
il protège sa il enferme le fou encore
mieux jouer et enfin 4 c'est bien joué
ça et maugrée qui va craquer je pense
pas qu'ils réussissent à le faire tomber
tours à 6 tours b 6
si on prend les cinq était un pion
province inquiétait un coup
alors qu'ils poussent des deux côtés ça
va pas le faire alors ça va se jouer
avec barbarian a réussi à la gagner
alors barbarian 50 secondes chacun la
partira au bout contre leafs normalement
il reste une minute 58 dans le tournoi
mais il faut la gagner
après ça a l'air d'aller ya pièce de
plus la qualité et non il ya qualité de
moins mais l'activité des noirs est
juste dingue et les barbes à rennes
s'est fait rattraper par jules lui ce ne
sera pas un français qui gagnera l'aréna
les amis vous allez voir julius juste à
rattraper les jeunes y ont refait un
tour après non non on va enfin si vous
voulez vous pouvez refaire un tour après
mais moi j'arrêterai le stream à ce
moment là parce que je vais pas on va
pas repartir aura fait un tournoi plus
court on va pas repartir sur sur deux
heures de tournoi sans a fait une demi
heure de moins aujourd'hui
mais bon c'était bon tournant à faire ça
a permis de faire autre chose et puis
d'essayer de 960 et finalement et c'est
même pas sûr qu'ils la gagnent 20
secondes chacun
les traits sont le tournoi est mort pour
lui mais il a bien joué avec les blancs
contre clouage bien joué à d'avoir deux
barbarian la finale est nul mais il est
mieux au temps et gérant plus vite que
son adversaire
donc il va gagner il pourrait finir
deuxième au mieux ce qui est déjà un bon
résultat
j'ai un excellent résultat pion qui part
c'est bien joué faux 5 pour éviter les
prêts move et sagan côté barbarian et on
va voir le classement et non il va finir
troisième peut-être même pas à ses
revenus par l'arrière on va voir le
classement qui va arriver là ouais
barbarian à qui finit avec 36 avait fini
premier ex-aequo alors mais au départage
troisième
j'imagine au nombre de victoires ou je
sais pas quoi en tout cas il finit
troisième
il n'était pas loin il s'est bien battu
voilà 3 + 0 c'est un peu court fut
d'accord tard hall pour le 960 pour s 3
+ 2 ou 5 + 0 c'est plus adapté
on dit qui est content il a fait top 10
c'est bien joué il a fait 10e mais
dommage hein pas de français premier les
étrangers étaient trop forts pour nous
aujourd'hui
il était beaucoup beaucoup trop fort
pour nous ils nous ont trusté les deux
premières places
elle s'était pas notre jeu c'était pas
notre jeu n'était pas notre jeu on va du
coup les gars merci d'avoir suivi je
vais remettre une petite pause du conte
fini aujourd'hui comme le disait un peu
plus tôt de vue du problème de la
création de tournoi demain ce sera avec
sami donc vous retrouverez sami pour
l'aréna j'imagine classique si jamais il
n'y a pas de nouveau des des mises à
jour des machins sinon ce sera de
nouveau une arena un peu un peu
différente et banon se retrouvent ce
soir pour le title tuesday et après
jeudi soir jeudi sera samedi au 6ème
pour pour l'aréna avec la fédération
française
du coup jeudi soir à 20h30 je vous
remercie à tous d'avoir suivi et je vous
dis à très bientôt et à ce soir et
weight watchers toujours en 3 + 2 ciao
ciao bye à la pub est parti et on se
retrouve ce soir